the despair you described in the book
when you have to you know hear scream
they were your heroes they took you into
the band
and now you're gonna join nirvana and
you felt really really bad and your mom
she says to you i know you feel bad
about leaving scream but sometimes
you just have to put your needs in front
of other people's and you said you know
that's it's weird my mother told me that
because she never put her needs
in front of mine she you know you know
what i what i eventually realized howard
was what she was referring to was my
parents divorce
she said sometimes you have to do what's
best for you
as i was writing the book i realized oh
[ __ ] that's what she needed to do to
survive when my parents broke up and
it's i mean and it was hard you know it
was really hard for me to leave my
buddies and join this new band of
strangers i hadn't met nirvana when i
first joined the band i just flew up
there [ __ ] moved in with kurt in this
tiny little apartment and now i'm
surviving on three corn dogs a day
there's a gap yeah i had three corn dogs
for 99
that was like now i got to budget that
but there was the [ __ ] music and that
was the thing that kept you alive so how
did you know did kurt play you some
songs and you knew he was going to be
great or the band was just starting to
make some noise what was going on that
you knew to leave scream
there was a record um there was a record
before the record never mind nirvana had
a record called bleach they had i was
their fifth drummer they had a bunch of
drummers
but this kid this guy chad channing was
our drummer he had left so i knew that
record because it was really popular in
the underground and the cool thing about
it was like you know it was like noisy
like dissonant punk rock cool songs but
then there was a song called about a
girl in the middle of the record which
is like i mean it sounds like something
off of an early beatles record it's like
a lennon mccartney song and you're
listening to you're like oh [ __ ] this
kid can do that too holy [ __ ] and so we
had a mutual friend and they said
nirvana were looking for a drummer and
they had seen me play and they were like
you know if we can get a guy like that
like it might be cool and so i called
him talked to him on the phone and they
said if you want come up fly up
and so then i was at this this
crossroads where what do i do do i stay
in los angeles stranded the band had
broken up we were staying with the
singer and the guitarist's uh sister was
a [ __ ] mud wrestler at the hollywood
tropicana and we were staying at her
house
in uh laurel canyon and i'm like really
am i this is the rest of my life really
like now i'm in l.a in laurel canyon
like [ __ ] and so i just i called my
mom she was right i took the chance and
i flew up to seattle
and you know it happened and and really
kurt was a good i mean you guys were
into the same music you guys had the
same influences it made sense but jesus
from a financial standpoint those guys
had screamed they were pissed right they
were just like you [ __ ] they were
bombed when i left they were bombed yeah
i mean and more than anything musical i
think just as friends like we had been
through so much [ __ ] [ __ ] together
dude like all of those tours where
touring squats
like [ __ ] squats in europe where you
show up and they're pirating electricity
they're burning the linens out front
because there's a scabies outbreak and
[ __ ] like that you know yeah and there's
like [ __ ] skinheads everywhere and
it's always like you kind of you band
together
right in a situation like that and so so
to to to decide to leave those guys and
like move on with my next phase of life
it was difficult oh there's so many good
stories i don't even know i mean i just
love the idea that when you join nirvana
and things start to pop and all the
record companies are interested in you
guys and you get like a 400 check and
you bought a bb gun and a [ __ ] idiot
how are you
i mean really when i was a kid and you
know what i think a lot of [ __ ] rock
musicians do the same thing like when
you grow up you know my mother was a
public school teacher we never had any
[ __ ] money like i didn't have money
for a baby gun
right nintendo or any of that [ __ ] so
when i finally got 400 bucks to me that
was like winning the [ __ ] lottery
yeah what i did was i went and i bought
all the [ __ ] i didn't have when i was a
[ __ ] kid
and then one week later i'm back to the
[ __ ] corn dogs for 99 cents like what
the [ __ ] was i thinking